m
ce mercredi 17 février a lieu
l'inauguration du pont de la rivière du
mât cet ouvrage d'art de 65 mètres de
long s'est vu offrir une nouvelle
jeunesse pour un montant total de 1
million 800 mille euros axe stratégique
entre les communes de saint-andré de
bras panon il est emprunté chaque jour
par plus de 7000 véhicules
ici on est sur un des ouvrages d'art un
conte à dimension historique parce qu'il
a été construit en 1860 parce qu'il a
été fait de manière architecturel par
les plus grands avec eiffel et donc on
ne pouvait pas ne pas réhabiliter ce
concours il y est inscrit l'histoire un
peu de réunionnaises et puis je vous dis
la préservation les ouvrages d'art que
nous avons et nous en avons 400 conseil
départemental dix mois de travaux ont
été nécessaires pour rendre cette
liaison accessible aux pannes au nez et
au saint-andréen en effet cet ouvrage
présentait de graves défauts qui ont
retardé sa réouverture
c'était dur parce que il ya une bête
juste et importante de l'ensemble la
structure métallique de ce pont qui a
compliqué beaucoup les choses et les
travaux qui devaient durer six mois mais
se sont prolongées de dix mois nous
malgré l'implication forte de
l'entreprise pour réduire au plus la
durée de ces travaux c'est un outil
essentiel de déplacement c'est le trait
d'union entre salazie saint-andré et
bras panon dix mois de travaux qui ont
diminué les passages selon les
commerçants la fermeture du pont a causé
une baisse de fréquentation
rétablissement du trait d'union entre
bras panon et cela tomberait le
rétablissement aussi du flux économiques
entre
ces deux villes on était un peu pâle à
paralyser sans ce pont c'était dur mais
ça y est le pont ont tenu un grand pont
et les clients commencent bien retourner
les gens
reprendre la route et c'est bien ces
travaux de réhabilitation ont été
financées par le conseil départemental
ainsi que par des fonds européens du
soir je prends de la rivière du mât
ouvrages d'art historiques et trait
d'union entre deux communes a encore de
beaux jours devant lui